Bonjour à tous, alors oui, je sais, je suis l'un des derniers sur Terre à ne jamais avoir fais de top 1 solo sur Fortnite... C'est la honte.
J'suis carrément trop nul mais aujourd'hui, j'vais essayer de me concentrer.
J'vais faire une session spéciale où je vais tryhard
Je vais jouer le mieux possible avec vous en direct sur twitch
pour essayer de faire le premier top 1 solo de toute ma vie
Je croise les doigts, soyez avec moi, encouragez moi, ça se passe maintenant.
Let's GO !!!
On est parti pour une première partie,
ça à intérêt à être énorme et sec.
Ma souris ?
Bah écoute, c'est une très très belle Razer que je vous montre.
Regardez, très très belle Razer, assez classique,
c'est grâce à elle que je fais très très peu de top 1. Allez LET'S GO !
*Beatbox*
J'ai pris une zone complètement où il y a personne là, j'vais peut être me faire ièch.
Alors j'ai pas joué depuis quelques temps
mais c'est justement quand on a pas joué depuis longtemps
que souvent il y a tout qui ce passe, on va pas commencer à être pessimiste.
On va voir ce que ça donne.
On va faire nos petits bails calmement comme d'habitude.
J'ai un mal de crâne, c'est un truc de ouf..
Qui a un peu fait la teuf hier ? Hier, c'était vendredi vous avez un peu bougé, vous
êtes sortis, vous avez fait quoi ?
C'est pour moi indispensable de le savoir sinon je vais très très mal dormir , c'est nécessaire.
Ah un pistolet, on apprécie.
Ah et non merci les partiels.
Putain, ça révise
Vous êtes dans les partiels en ce moment c'est chaud
J'avais oublié ce mot, quoi, le mot partiel
C'est un mot qui me donne des boutons personnellement.
je suis très heureux d'avoir terminé l'école hein j'vous l'dis
même si finalement on arrête jamais de travailler dans la vie
ok, on encourage Adrien qui doit rendre un mémoire de 40 pages le p'tit pote putain
Youtuber rime avec chômeur, huhumm, ça dépends, pas toujours
Mais c'est vrai, qu'il faut avoir de la chance pour ça
bon peut etre faut faire les choses calmement un petit peu
ah yes ! qui a osé tirer la ?
MON DIEU !! Ce kill était insane (incroyable)
OK, j'ai fait mon premier kill de la journée. Je pouvais dire qu'il est pas dégueulasse.
Voilà. C'est comme ça que je me démerde en fait... OULA. Ah, yes. C'est quoi ça ?
Merde (beaucoup de fois).
OK, deuxième kill. Apparemment, les gens me cherchent des noises.
Je crois qu'il ont mal compris qui j étais.
En fait, moi je joue comme ça tout le temps. Ça vous dérange pas ? Vous êtes pas habitués peut être . En fait les gens me font aucun dégâts.
Je suis juste un ultra "fragueur".
Je n'en ai plus rien à secouer. C'est parti pour un formidable TOP 1,
les frérots. Par contre je vais peut-être prendre ça.
9, ouais, ça m’intéresse.
Par contre, j'avais pas vu la zone. Ça, c'est chiant. On va effectuer nos bails, trrrrèèèèès
calmement.
Voilà, comme ceci les frérots. On en a plus rien à foutre.
Où sont nos carrières ? Je vous le demande. Alors là, je vais faire un truc très cool. Regardez. HOP
Pratique ! Malin ! On n'a pas le temps en fait.
Bon. On va essayer de se la jouer bien caché. On va vraiment chercher le TOP 1.
On va vraiment jouer sérieusement. Il y a un mec là-bas, qui construit.
Il faut les laisser s'entretuer en fait.
Il y a du monde là, hein.
Je suis mal parti, là. C'est là que tout le monde me voit, c'est ça qui est chiant.
Je ne vais pas perdre mes munitions pour rien. Ça serait un peu dommage.
Là, il y a un tremplin, c'est très bien.
Je ne sais même pas d'où il me tire le mec. Ah oui, il a vraiment la... Vous savez le sniper
archi lourd. Je ne sais même plus comment il s appelle. Le "barrett", c'est ça ?
OULA ! C'est moi ! It's me ! Pourquoi je fais ça ? Pourquoi je fais des bêtises, moi ?
On va essayer de faire un petit truc un peu bizarre comme ça.
J'ai pas envie qu'on me fasse "iech". Bon, bah voilà, on n'est pas dégueulasse.
On a deux petits frags. On va essayer de la jouer comme on m'a expliqué.
C'est-à-dire très safe, d'accord ? Ah, il y a un mec là.
Il sait que je sais. La connerie serait de me prendre un headshot (tir dans la tête).
Donc je vais vraiment me calmer.
*Bêlement*. Ah ! Merci... Merci pour le petit sub', là, c'est cool.
Oh non, c'est Martha qui s'est abonné ! Merci martha_du_standard !
On l'applaudit s'il vous plaît ! Je me dis pourquoi elle rigole là.
Bon, il y a de l'action, mais ça se passe derrière les arbres. 6 personnes.
C'est juste "fat-tissime" ce qu'il se passe !
Est-ce que ça va être le premier TOP 1 ou pas ? Il reste 5 et demi.
J'irais bien dans la baraque, mais je suis sûr qu'il y a du monde là-bas.
Merde, il est là-bas.
Mouais. C'est pas ouf ce que je fais là. C'est pas ouf du tout. Faut que j'aille dans la baraque, je pense.
Ils se tirent dessus, c'est parfait. J'en profite pour me barrer. Ah non ! La maison n'est pas dans la zone.
Y a un cum, je vais ma casser, tout de suite.
J'arrive hein les frérots. Là je suis en TOP 1 ! Il en reste 2, les frérots.
OOOOOOHHHHHH !
MY GOD !
Mon premier TOP 1  est effectué !
Ce moment est historique !
AHAHA !
Yeah ! Putain !
C'est mon premier TOP 1 SOLO ! Après un an de Fortnite ! HAHA !
WAOUH ! C'est un truc de ouf ce qu'il vient de se passer là ! J'ai pas... J'ai pas les mots. Ça tue !
Pu**** les amis je suis allé jusqu'au bout la! Pu**** j'suis trop content! Ça tue. Bon un Screenshot comment on fait le screenshot?
Screenshot la, imprime écran. Ça tue
Heu je pense que ça mérite quand même un p'tit débriefe. J'ai quand même fait 4
frag. Donc  j'vais enregistrer ce hight light.
Clippez moi ça les amis!
Parce que c'est pas... C'est pas tous les jours qu'on fait ceci. En plus pu****
C'était un peu merdique cette dernière heuuu
Ce dernier kill là, il était un peu pourri
Halala! C'est trop cool!!
C'est trop trop bien pu****
C'est génial! Heuu j'pensais qu'jétais pas bon en fait? Baa j'crois que la j'ai
fait 4 kill Top 1... Après
Voila, on en reparle, merci Yann
Pour le host. Finalement tu vois ces des viewers qui sont venus apprécier heuu
un gros gaming
La je remate mon kill
ah ouais !! Le dernier
Le dernier coup que je lui ai mis c'était un 74 donc c'était pas un p'tit coup en fait
On va faire un truc très simple, on va simplement allez voir
Regardez ça... Ouais ok, une victoire!
En solo haha
Hee, je pense qu'on peut... On peut apprécier ce chiffre. En vrai
Quand j'ai vu marqué "Top 1" j'ai fait " je suis pas habitué à ça, je comprend pas, c'est quoi ce truc?
ah ouais c'est un Top 1 j'avais jamais fait!" Hésitez pas à envoyer ce clip à tous
vos potes
Le Top 1 à été éffectué!! Merci de m'avoir
encouragé, de m'avoir donné cette force! Ce moment
est vraiment historique, je ne l'oublierais jamais! Suivez-moi
Sur ma chaîne Twitch : twitch.tv/normanstream   Je joue régulièrement
Le mardi soir et le dimanche en fin d'après midi et soirée
Ca s'appelle le stream dominical
Donc venez nombreux, on s'amuse bien ! On se retrouve bientôt
pour une prochaine session de jeu video électronique. Je vous apprécié énormément!
tchao!!!